what was your budget for absol IDIA and
how did you figure out what cost - a lot
the budget was about 120 and we started
out looking to make it for a hundred
yeah so I had this idea and I had worked
with a Scottish producer who I knew had
a hundred thousand dollars to put into a
movie and he had said to me he'd offer
hundred thousand dollars to three
filmmakers to make movies and they had
all said well can I use that to raise
more money and he had said no you have
to make it for a hundred thousand and he
said he really blew me away that then
they just passed on it you know and I
like I just stored that story in my head
and when I had finished writing obsolete
eeeh I said to you know we said okay
let's hit him up with a hundred thousand
dollars and let's make this movie four
hundred thousand dollars and so I at
that point we sought a line producer to
make a budget cuz we said okay we want
to go to this guide as possible investor
and be able to say to him
here's the script you know we want a
hundred thousand dollars that you
offered to three other filmmakers and
they turned you down we're gonna make a
movie four hundred thousand dollars and
here's the budget and here's how we're
gonna do it you know here's a schedule
and here's like everything and we're
gonna make this movie four hundred
thousand and so we then sought a line
producer on Craigslist to do our budget
for us I put a lovely ad on Craigslist I
met a lot of different line producers
and one of them was Matt Medellin who
came on board too to do that and he was
like I can make a budget for a hundred
thousand dollars a bunch of them just
said you cannot make this movie for
hundred thousand dollars but so we
started really with that thing of
budgeting the movie like how do we make
this movie for that amount you know
there's two ways to approach a budget
one is sort of like how much does
everything cost and then add it up and
see what it is and the other way is how
do we make this movie possible for that
amount and so you know then we had to
get real you know to make the movie hope
four hundred thousand dollars we had to
lose something from the script mm-hmm
you know so and and change things you
know in the original script that he had
you know there was like animals it was
like a cat that was like it's sort of
character in the movie know there was a
little kid on you know there was like
you know so there was things like that
it was just sort of like oh you know
this is gonna make it you know the
things that are not gonna be possible on
this budget and I was absolutely
obsessed with this has to be doable it
has to be realistic on this budget I
don't want to be making a movie that's
like over ambitious for the price
because I know that's like a short you
know ticket to failure so we were served
we worked and worked on the script as
well and like I cut locations for
instance after the main couple go on
their date there was a lovely scene in a
cafe or restaurant and said I made it
his house you know so it's things like
that so it's just like getting creative
with the script to make it doable for a
hundred thousand you know during the
process of meeting the line producers I
also met one young man called Ken Morris
who was just really lovely and super
enthusiastic about the project he was
just out of university so we felt like
he probably didn't have the necessary
experience so I be the producer you know
like be a producer on the film but it
ended up the the producer that we the
investor that we'd initially hope to get
100,000 from mamantov invest some money
in it but he situation has changed for
him and he didn't want to invest as much
as a hundred thousand and he did love
the project and became very you know
involved with it yeah and it was very
involved in the development of it but he
then didn't have the money to put up for
it and so suddenly we were like oh my
god what are we gonna do who are we
gonna get the money from and Ken Morris
this young guy who I'd met as a possible
line producer you know he was and I just
said let's keep him involved and you
know he's terrific young man suddenly
you know he said I think I think perhaps
I can get the money and he actually
brought in a large part of the money and
then we kicked in and then we kicked
into the rest from our savings so it was
like piecemealed together so this
original person that had offered this a
hundred thousand was totally out no you
have investing him and yep I think
putting in a percentage yeah yeah they
know but no not the not the hundred
thousand that weird hopeful yeah sure
what cost the most in our budget
initially interestingly enough initially
one of the biggest ticket items
we were going to be shooting out in the
desert for twelve days with a cast and a
crew and water was very expensive
believe it or not it was a really high
price because there's certain things you
can't get around you know like when
we're shooting in the city so I mean our
locations were actually incredibly low
cost because we shot where we live
yeah and we got this little quarters for
a very small amount of money and you
know shooting the desert you don't have
to pay for shooting you know we didn't
get permits we you know shot in the
desert so our location costs were very
low but there's some things you can't go
around like giving people water in the
desert
you need to have water and you need to
have a lot of it because you're in the
middle of the Mojave Desert I guess like
actually just like catering and and
accommodation for everyone when we were
staying in the desert we slept in a tent
in the desert literally is that
everybody else was bust in and out you
know and they were bused to the town
that was nearest but it was still like
40 minutes away or something yes so
twelve days eleven days we stay that
does I mean I think in the tent where
the Coyotes and the wild burros and
donkeys and got real dirty snakes yeah
so that's where we stayed so we saved
the production some money we did but I
think that like I think I gave her a
crew like heart the fact that they left
set everyday in a bus and they were we
were like going into our tent sort of
you know made them work a little extra
hard every day for us yeah so
accommodations water what was next
accommodations water and the the other
big-ticket item was kind of the camera
equipment at the time because we needed
we needed backup drives and hard drives
and the camera batteries the red camera
was we all know at that time like I
think a large percentage of our budget I
think we put about $10,000 into set
design and art direction and you know
that was a choice that we made we I
still feel very strongly like it's funny
a lot of people will spend
money on the camera and then you know
shoot in front of a white wall it's like
it's not gonna look great you know like
what you put in front of the camera is
so important for creating a great look
for your film it's not all about the
camera it's about what's in front of her
and so we felt very clear that like what
was gonna make this movie come alive and
be amazing was creating these two
particular worlds the world of George
and then also the world of the
scientists out in the desert we created
that set completely from scratch and so
we definitely like I know
comparatively and I remember talking
about with Matt like we know when you
would go through the budget we spent so
much time all the time as you do line by
line where can we save how can we cut
you know and that was something that was
high percentage wise in our budget but I
think it really really did pay off and
it's funny cuz like I think that was
like ten thousand dollars compared to
for instance our wardrobe costs were
five hundred dollars for the whole movie
so you see you know it's like it's these
choices that you make but I think
costuming you know you can pull things
together if it's if it's contemporary
obviously you know if you're shooting
and it's something you can pull things
together pretty cheaply and easily but
what you're putting in front of the
camera like you know the decoration of
places and what those worlds are like I
just think it's so crucial and it's
really somewhere that is worth spending
more money yeah definitely shows
especially where he lives I mean it's
artistic it's an artist film when it was
all said and done 120,000 how much were
you sort of over budget I know a hundred
thousand sounded like that was what you
wanted with post yeah how did that why
and that's why like ultimately the film
was more expensive than we had
originally but I think even like I think
actually our budget when we finally when
we went to production had already moved
up to about 105 or something you know
and then and then continue and continue
to move up so it did it it was sort of
like over budget the shoot wasn't over
budget the shoot stayed completely
within the the the thing that we hadn't
fully bought homes for realistically was
was post you know in particular sound
which was more expensive than we
anticipate yeah because of wind and the
desert or well that did play a factor in
it it did there was some kinda
but I noticed it was very clean the
whistling my shoes but we did play a
factor in it because we paid for a
decent sound mix I mean we had a great
sound recorders on set it's a mixer Tom
Carly who was phenomenal and he did a
great job and he got us great sound but
then I think you know and it's just that
thing like you know for a film to work
it the sound doesn't need to be half
decent and we did so we did end up
spending a decent bit of money to get a
proper professional sound mix done you
know and I think a lot of those tiny
butt movies don't do that
and you know because it is expensive and
it does kill them you can't kill them we
weren't we weren't on that as much as we
should have been from the get-go again
it gets into building your team earlier
as opposed to waiting till the last
minute we if we'd have built that team a
little earlier I think we probably would
have been in a position where we could
have negotiated a better price with the
sound yeah with the people that we chose
but they saw that we were behind the
eight-ball so they basically you know
pushed dare agenda more than ours
you